[Music]
[Applause]
Greg Bard the uh founder editorial
director of Boston Sports journal.com
covered the Patriots for a long time
with Sports Illustrated Boston Globe
where do we stand on all this situation
with uh bill bich and the Patriots uh
with this report that Tom Curran had
this
week uh Dan it's a good question um you
know my my personal feeling and um look
this
is this is a story that uh is going to
be held very close to the vest um you
know between Robert Bill and Jonathan um
nothing definitive that I've heard uh
from inside or outside the building um
points one way or the other I certainly
have my feelings on this and I don't
necessarily think it's the case that um
that the Colts game was sort of the the
final straw I mean this has been going
on for a couple of years and you got to
think even even with the Colts loss and
it would be natural for the crafts to
sit and think about this decision during
the bye after that game uh possibly meet
with Bill I still they were two and
eight at the time stranger things have
happened in football where they the
Patriots could have won out at 9 and8 um
you know but do think the die was cast
at that point I think it' been cast for
a while so I think that um I think that
both sides have an idea on what's going
to happen it's likely that that they
will part ways um after decision I just
after the season I just have a hard time
telling you one way the other how
definitive it is and I was just
wondering if it's in the the personality
of Robert Craft to have had a meeting
with Bill bellich with this many games
to go and then he would give him a heads
up like hey Bill this is what this is
what we're going to do at season end I I
just I don't know their relationship but
that would surprise me if he's saying
hey instead of saying let's talk about
when the season's over with and then you
know we can decide how we want to play
this that's normally their MO Dan is
that they will get to the end of the
season and they will come together and
and you know there's a few different
factors at play here um number one
people H I think people underestimate
how much last season and ticked off the
crafts um they they they were mad about
what happened they thought okay we dealt
with the we had a reset year with Cam
Newton Tom Brady went and won a Super
Bowl with the Buccaneers that really
hurt but it looked like things were
going up for the franchise drafted to M
Jones in the first round they signed uh
they set a record in terms of the money
they spent in free agency that year they
went 10- seven they went to the playoffs
things were looking up and then bill
made his decision with Matt Patricia and
Joe judge and the reaction from the
crafts
was this doesn't make a lot of sense to
us bill but you've you've earned the
right to make this decision and when
that that decision clearly was a mistake
uh they were by the end of the season
they were Furious and they needed to
hear the right things from Bill at the
end of last season or else it might have
ended there um from what I understand
Bill said the right things they were
like okay he set a new course he he
admitted that uh that
underestimated what the offense needed
how much Josh McDaniels had done for him
but he was he was willing to be open to
Corrections with Billy O'Brian and so
where they went into 20
2023 if you look at all the tea leaves
in terms of they have so many top tier
free agents that have not been extended
to me it looked like okay the craft said
to bill you get your you got your
Mulligan okay but if it doesn't work
this season you got a chance to to put
it on its right tracks if it doesn't
work this season we all know where this
is going leave 2024 to somebody else
we'll make that decision when we get
there how attractive is this
job
well uh it's a good question I mean I in
terms of the crafts the franchise the
stability you know you got to look at it
I mean you know they've hired two
coaches in their ownership tenure Pete
Carroll who uh if I recall correctly
lasted about three years and you know
didn't do all that bad a job
but the the craft decided they needed
more and they brought they brought bill
in and and Robert was just on NFL game
day talking about stability I mean they
do do a good job of that they they hire
people really smart people and let them
go do their job so in terms of the
stability of ownership what they're
going to give you to do your job I think
it's an extremely attractive job now are
you getting into the quarterback and the
roster and things like
that you know that's nice but that's not
how a lot of these guys think in terms
of jobs there first of all there's one
there's only you know one of 32 jobs in
the world and then then you look at
ownership and it doesn't get much better
than the Patriots ownership how
attractive Will Bill bellich be on the
open
market that is a good question I I think
that I think he'll have some appeal to
some franchises in terms
of you know face value bringing uh sort
of a credibility to a franchise let's
say like the commanders that is you know
just nobody knows what their brand is
Bill is a is a brand um I think the
national brand is better than the local
brand in New England at this point um I
I would be very interested to know what
he is open to in terms of structure I
mean me personally from covering him up
close and watching his team up close I
would not not be interested in giving
him total control over an organization
the coach the game
planner yes I'm interested in that
Personnel control salary cap control how
he constructs a roster I'm not
interested in
that should be interesting the uh next
few weeks and you got Kansas City with
the Patriots coming up Greg we
appreciate your time as always thank you
anytime guys that's Greg Bard founder
and editorial director of Boston Sports
journal.com he's covered the the
Patriots used to be with Sports
Illustrated and the Boston glob